Cuba's cigars are considered among the
best in the world and perhaps the best
in Cuba a role from tobacco grown here
in the province of Pina Del Rio here
they're short because they have enough
Sun if an rodrigues Ramirez has spent
the past seven years working for a
family called Raveena which has spent
the past 170 years working the land here
is this farm
a typical tobacco farm in Cuba this is
unique unique because these 42 acres
constitute the largest private
plantation on the island providing the
tobacco for one in 20 of the country's
premium cigars are in high-quality but
high quality does not necessarily
generate great wealth this is just for
drying and changing the color in a state
controlled industry in a communist
country
the government creates and controls the
entire market they don't share with us
anything it doesn't work in Cuba like
that so they sell the cigars and they
get the profits workers earn less than
$50 a month in factories like this where
each year a hundred million cigars are
rolled and sold smokers in the US are
blocked from buying these Cuban brands
but still purchase 300 million
hand-rolled cigars from other countries
if the US embargo ends the current
market for Cuban cigars would be
squeezed and increased demand would only
be met if more rollers get trained
and more tobacco gets grown by farmers
like Karachi Raveena hua thorium he's
the fifth generation of his family to
enter the business I need a cigar we'll
get you hooked up right away but on a
recent visit to New York
Harger a man Cuba's best-known tobacco
grow was marketing a new high price
cigar the best cigar smoking use made of
tobacco grown in Nicaragua do you think
the Cuban government would like a cigars
to be sold in America of course of
course why it's a good business it's
very good business but good business in
the US may not benefit Robina don't love
opera
unless Cuban authorities alter property
rules that prevent him from expanding
his farm where annual revenues today
totaled just 40 thousand US dollars when
you see a box of cigars made from your
tobacco selling for hundreds of dollars
how does that make you feel
I know that with my cigars we find
medicines for hospitals remember in my
country is a poor country I know in
another place we can make more money but
I live in Cuba now I love my country I
try to help my people also rich
sentiments and poor profits are common
in a country where state-controlled
Commerce remains a certain for its
citizens as taxes are for most Americans